says holidays like music and of course
disneyland jillian got a preview of all
the holiday happenings there including
the first parade to return to the park
for guests since the reopening take a
look
all right well i have my sequins on
because we are celebrating today a
christmas fantasy parade returns for the
first time to guests since the reopening
and it's a really exciting moment and i
have to bring in my friend carlos over
here we are in front of it's a small
world we're kicking it off thank you so
much for being here carlos for being
here we're so excited that you and all
of your guests in las vegas are ready to
join us for the holidays and the
holidays just wouldn't be complete
without a gingerbread man and exactly an
entire gingerbread house behind us so
let's talk a little bit about this flow
and why it's so special to the parade
well as you know
we're super excited to welcome all of
our guests back and it's been 23 months
since we've seen a christmas fantasy
parade so i don't know about you but for
me like i just get like the chills and
just the emotions because we we missed
everyone we miss all of our guests we
miss our parade and the gingerbread
cookies and you know just it's that time
like it's definitely that time to come
and celebrate and enjoy a christmas
fantasy parade and you definitely hit my
emotions right there because when i
walked in and i saw the tree and i saw
the lights and everything i got the
chills it just made me so happy again
and this parade is quite the parade
let's talk about how many performers are
in what people can expect it's really a
production it really is our gingerbread
has about 99 other performers that join
him every day so it's really fun to come
and see the performers and not just the
gingerbread cookie but we have the
bakers and we have
our ballroom dancers our princesses you
can't have a parade without our disney
princesses mickey mouse minnie mouse all
of her friends and of course the big guy
himself santa claus it wouldn't be
complete without santa but it sounds
like you have everyone that you need
right here part of the parade and let's
talk a little bit you said that this
parade was part of the very first one
and you're bringing it back it's a
special year it is a special year this
is the 25th presentation of a christmas
fantasy parade so we're super excited to
present it to everyone because it i
for me i grew up with this parade so i
remember being a kid and sitting down
with my churro my gingerbread cookie i
thought i would eat yes
and just watching the parade i grew up
also that was this is one of my first
roles at being a dancer in this parade
so i have a special connection
personally with this parade that i just
love it so much and this float like we
were saying has been here since day one
of the princess fantasy parade so since
1995. ah that is so amazing super lucky
that it's still here we have our
gingerbread that's still happy and
dancing
just the smells the you know it's the
disneyland holidays it really is nothing
better it's like churros are in the air
and if people want to catch the parade
when can they see it and where does it
happen in the park that is a very good
question so it'll step off either here
at it's a small world or at the entrance
of the park in town square we always
advise our guests to check the
disneyland app or go on our website
because we typically like to present the
parade twice a day but entertainment is
subject to change without notice and
it's better just check the app get the
correct times for the the particular day
that you're here and
i mean you just want to check on the app
to begin with to make your reservations
and see all everything that's going on
so you're set you're ready to come in
enjoy and not have to worry about
anything other than getting the perfect
spot for a christmas fantasy parade and
waving toward your favorite gingerbread
cookie oh well life is good then right
carlos thank you so much yes this is so
beautiful it makes me so happy to be
here and i might just be moving into
this gingerbread house behind so don't
tell anyone okay i i mean if our
gingerbread cookie's okay with sharing
oh i think that's a yes that's
definitely a yes i'm jealous
thank you so much carlos i'll send it
back to you guys
how cute jason i say we dress you up in
the gingerbread man suit perfect